hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to shadows - now this indie
or game just came out yesterday it's
very recent but it's already getting
good reviews not that I know it's about
because I've never played shadows one
but I always play things out of order
because that's how markiplier do so it's
barely past midnight at the office
wonder what's gonna happen oh oh it's
got camera whoa what was that
it was a book flying across the room
okay ah for a second there I thought it
was gonna be like five nights at
Freddy's style but it doesn't look like
that maybe it's okay oh wait does that
make me a security guard or was I just
weirdly looking at the security cameras
why am i at an office alone open
inventory you can enable disable object
hints in the options oh cool personal
notes I was about to go home while this
happened all cameras died instantly for
no actual reason I saw some weird stuff
on the screen and I just don't know what
to say I need to get my stuff and check
out the office I'm scared as hell hey
I'll be the judge of that you don't let
me tell me who be scared alright it's a
switch flashlight mode oh it's got a
brightness setting cool is that gonna
drain the batteries faster maybe hello
see I'm really glad that I've kind of
branched out back into doing these indie
horror games because number one you
never know what you're gonna get
I mean a lot of these indie horror games
they kind of go on the jump-scare trope
but occasionally you'll come across an
interesting little game that has a you
know it has a premise and it has a story
and it has an environment these are all
generic things that I'm saying but I'm
trying to be intellectual about what I'm
saying but you never know what you're
gonna get once you go into it so you can
see oh well why is this blocked off
hello can I move this thank you
what was that what was that
hello I don't think I want to go there I
want to go there I'm an idiot I run it
face-first into danger I want to give it
a big old kiss come out come out
wherever you are
Marky's gonna get you oh I don't know
what this is note is for I like to write
stuff when I'm bored I remember being
here for the very first time and I
couldn't remember where this is the exit
it's not in this corridor maybe the
second one and turn right maybe now I
won't forget that all right time to get
back to work what does that mean
how how much could you forget that you
need to write things down to remember
how to get out of the building when
you're bored
well that's bizarre anyway thanks boo
bye lady for that handy hint was there
something down there no all right try
the other corridor and go right I don't
know about that there we go how about I
stop being a big [ __ ] and just go down
the corridor that would be good hello
come out come out wherever what am I
looking at something huh
don't wanna mess with me huh huh there's
no power well that's a problem hmm
seems like there might be a monster
around here something that wants to mess
with me
oh hello what the hell whoa why am i
back here what the [ __ ] happened
wait what happened what did I die
what happened who's that oh hey wait a
minute
whoa wait a minute what the hell oh my
question exactly what the hell just
happened how did I get back there oh no
you do not
oh well can those come out forever
oh really monkeys come fast
okay we're fine nothing happened nothing
actually happened okay
alright we're fine everything's cool
whoa what the [ __ ] was that okay whoa
what what happened what happened I don't
know what happened was I was about to go
home all this happen what I don't even
know anymore is this happening in my
head and no I'm not that crazy I just
can't be I need to leave this place
okay well what happened I'm so confused
do I go back what the hell happened whoa
all right oh man
it's kind of reminds me of the Stanley
parable and its layout by the way just
wanted to say that so there was
something over here oh now there's
nothing over here huh
all right ways our powernow oh there's
power now I wouldn't have tried oh god
damn it who was at the door closing I'm
such a freakin idiot
god damn it gets spooked by a door why
am I going to floor nine what's here in
floor nine well the elevator doesn't let
me go all the way down there must be
something wrong but I don't really care
I need to get the heck out of here as
fast as I can
otherwise bad stuff may happen to me
well I have a funny feeling that bad
stuff is already happening to you bub
but you don't need to worry about that
at all okay I got your back
well come out come out wherever you are
um Lucky's gonna find you oh this looks
familiar
well I left the TV remote control in my
office in case you needed PS please end
your work before midnight that's a good
stratagem who's over there huh huh who's
that do you hear that
I heard that why does it seem like
exactly the same layout as the other
place seems like exactly the same layout
either someone is [ __ ] with mirror
this lazy level design I don't know
which I'm almost sure that's a human
hardened that sucks
oh good observation there buddy oh
you're such a keen observer
okay so this must unlock this over here
hello
no maybe I gotta use it no I don't have
anything in my inventory what that
doesn't make any goddamn sense but I
picked up a key I definitely did pick up
a key I'm a hundred percent sure that
axe woo I wrote this book for people who
want to know about the kind of
paranormal phenomena or so-called
shadows first of all they're not really
shadows er
pitch-black humanoid figures roaming
through the numerous locations if you
encountered them please keep reading
this book it's really important let me
just put that down I don't need to learn
about a goddamn thing do I okay so what
happened to the key that I had oh okay
so I needed the TV remote why do I need
that that doesn't seem like a break that
I should take in the middle of this
never all right here we go anyway ah
it is the action notification okay why
how does this affect me we interrupt
this program this is a national
emergency important instructions will
follow oh oh oh what door opened okay
let's see uh something caused the power
to go out it could be the TV but why
just why I'm seriously scared as [ __ ]
bro
I'm so scared bro alright this one open
yes it did come on come out wherever you
are
what are you doing in the bathroom I
like you oh [ __ ] off huh alrighty then
oh god damn it it's a mannequin how did
I know no idea what this thing is doing
in here well I don't either except
exclusively for jump scares alright then
so that's how you're gonna be okay see
this place I can't stand working here
anymore weird stuff is happening all the
time and I can't focus on my job I see
moving objects shadows creepy noises
coming from nowhere
I'm sorry boss that may be just my brain
but I really want to quit
sorry well no need to be sorry about it
you things are being spooked
spooked all over the place maximum
spewpa Jan I can't handle none of it
none of it okay well that didn't do jack
diddly [ __ ] ah here we go key got it
okay so I got that key so I should be
able to open the door down here leading
into the other corridor hey one drew
what who eats me so they're gonna pop
out at me mm-hmm anything maybe huh yes
did somebody fart whoa hello is that
some is that a thing is it it
how the [ __ ] do you think you uh yeah
you running away little [ __ ] baby huh
oh I see how it is oh oh this is good oh
hello oh hello come out come out
wherever you are
Marky's gonna find you
oh damn it god damn it Oh another heart
oh this is horrible apparently come out
come out whoa wherever Lucky's gone come
out come out wherever you but I didn't
go down over here oh it's so dark
did I miss something I'm gonna miss
something over here wink uh-huh vacuum
secret found I don't know if it was much
of a secret but I found it I don't know
what that's gonna do for me but I found
a secret carrying on yawn I don't know
where we're gonna go now floor eight god
damn it do I got old go all the way down
to floor one all these identical floors
mmm oh well somebody got dis mom bird oh
no someone lost an arm and a leg all
right so we got to find ya I've seen
worse stuff but this really makes me
sick okay
as a general office worker how have you
seen worse stuff than two legs displayed
out on your floor hello hi how you doing
mm-hmm that's my thoughts exactly
mm-hmm all right you stay there then
fine [ __ ] you I'll just carry on don't
mind hello good good
all righty then okay oh god why can I
get boob eyes back appreciate her more
than what you're doing right hello come
out come out where I don't think they
like me singing that song hmm this is
turning into a nightmare it seems like
something's following me something
unknown I need to stay calm and slowly
get all the way down once it happens I'm
free I don't know if that's gonna happen
I have a funny feeling that's not gonna
happen do you remember when you saw a
guy walking through the corridor and get
attacked by a weird black shape that was
horrifying I still have the tape so we
could check it out once again we need to
know what happened well that seems like
a warning sign for not being around here
anymore
probably okay hello well I'm not gonna
go in that just yet I got other places
to explore first like over y'all damn it
there's got to be a key to this Oh
whatever walks there I won't open this
door
well [ __ ] your big bubble blowing baby
come on get some balls on ya all right
fine here we go
goodbye oh hello
oh good I'm home free let me just sprint
towards my destiny I wanted to read that
issue
there was a note on the ground oh oh
okay
holy [ __ ] my chest I'm glad I didn't
fell unconscious okay cool
alrighty then carrying on
let's not fell unconscious anymore jeez
dammit Loucks oh that's a comforting
glow what do I need that Oh God
now I have that how is that going to
help me oh boy oh boy yeah boy yeah boy
oh okay wait hang on a second what's
going on here whoa yeah something bad
having air for a really good party maybe
find another secret for whatever that's
worth
oh boy alright I'm out of here I had
enough top pine time dancing on the pile
of dead bodies
alright let's carry on over here haven't
happy oh boy more I was hoping for more
dead bodies oh boy it's a smorgasbord oh
who does come on now
I don't look good huh maybe I'll avoid
that for now
maybe I'll go check out the other areas
before I walk into the elevator Adil
okay well let's go what's the worst that
could happen everybody else seemed to
have a good time over here
four seven god damnit how many floors
are there holy [ __ ]
Luke ooh how's it going baby how are you
doing baby you're not gonna say anything
about that what did I just pick up I
have no idea what I got well I got
something all righty then oh I don't
have a fast hello hi what happened to my
flashlight okay okay what happen to my
flashlight losing never ends my phone
barely works oh okay how did I get off
of my flashlight what the [ __ ] happened
holy [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you let me scream
Allah no real quick I'm so fearful but I
can raid something can take control over
my brain now I couldn't see anything I
swear I don't know what they want from
me me neither bro meanie whoo hey whoo
hey all right
fine then all right that's how it's
gonna be okay
goodbye goodbye goodbye all right
goodbye all right
god damn it dessert key in there that I
didn't get god damn huh there we go give
me that goodbye sayonara
and no home no and home don't come
knockin around here anymore right okay
blinking lights what a cliche damn it
locked door hi don't throw a box did you
throw this box mister dead lower body
I'm coming for you
great who and why and how well I wasn't
there before
whoa okay huh I'll go down
okay I think I scared him with my opera
shadows can appear in places like hotels
huge office building Center shops etc
there's only one known sighting in a
family home which is abandoned at this
moment and you're not allowed to visit
it not allowed family living in the
house is missing no one knows where they
could be the house of full black
splatters on the floor in walls people
walking near the house at night reported
seeing black figures standing in the
windows and hearing crackling sounds but
you're not allowed to see it
that'd be against the rules hi no one
here oh hey how's it going friends how
are you doing they are completely
unmovable for some reason huh well
that's bizarre oh well you late to the
party I'll do everything to punish you
for that you did the worst thing ever
possible leaving your office was a
really stupid move friend well it's not
like I had a choice oh man I did have a
bed in there but I guess I got to go out
to eat eventually come out come out
wherever you are
Maki gonna find you come out come on oh
okay whoa what are you conferring about
over there what are you doing I can feel
weird energy while standing near these
or maybe I'm just paranoid no I think
there's some weird energy going on you
know if I had a guesstimate apparently
they moved from here damn it
uh-huh you're gonna join me on this ride
[ __ ] okay door isn't concerning at all
floor six oh [ __ ] now I can only assume
that there's more floors to go for this
but I'm all out of time for this episode
so I'm gonna assume that it has a
loading feature so we'll get to the rest
of this in another episode
I'll probably just finish it out to the
very end but I just don't have any more
time to record right now so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
glasshouse can't brick rocks
Oh dick with me